and they're going to get a second
shot at brad keller in a week and they
gave brad a hard time last saturday in
st louis
[Applause]
well he made the adjustment there with
the fastball at 96. blew it right by it
paul goldschmidt hitting 274 goes after
the pitch and hits one high and deep to
center that goes taylor away back to
make the catch
right up against the wall
he had completely run out of room
[Applause]
so the ballpark barely held it with two
outs
aronado and o'neal get on and here comes
matt carpenter who isn't the player he
once was but he has done some of his
best work
here at kauffman stadium
[Applause]
rivera
has room as he goes over the railing
so keller
works in and out of it
and st louis is scoreless in the first
hey congratulations man and write my
record keep going keep doing what she's
doing man i love you and
keep working hard
so he has passed
alcitus escobar who passed
billy butler who passed
johnny damon
nice to pass willie wilson oh you're the
best partner quite a pick it up
beautiful
fans really appreciate him
the way he plays and the way he sets the
tone let's hope it's a good one tonight
this is his third start as a cardinal
most of these numbers are with the
nationals
oh
off of leicester it deflects to sosa and
his throw is going to be in time
you mentioned last night scott mcgregor
is another significant big leaguer from
el segundo
and lars
was rung up by home point empire ryan
attiton
but that was only strike two
everyone misses
he gave it right back to him
all right that's a beauty yeah but he
don't have to go there he's only got two
yeah two okay new bar showed him but
then right back there now newt barr you
got to go
two and one on emmanuel rivera formerly
with the baltimore orioles
there's a ground ball to the shortstop
flip the second out onto first double
play
on that 643 double play doubling up
taylor and rivera
edmundo sosa the ninth place hitter
so you're not supposed to be in the
lineup then they say you're in the
lineup and you start a double play
make a great play and a ball off of
leicester and you pick up a base hit
it's kind of how you end up getting in
the lineup a lot more isn't it
trying to over rotate certain pitches
kind of strikeout pitches
when there
is fewer than two strikes in the count
strikeout throw out
edmond is
quite confident that he was in there
salvi isn't going anywhere
paul was made by second base umpire
chris siegel
i think it's pretty clear he didn't make
contact until he got him on the back of
the left leg
wow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
his career off leicester and he's a 265
hitter
see that right there with the runner and
scoring position find a hole
and taylor hits it up the middle and
into center field
there's your hit with a runner in
scoring position and
the royals take a one-nothing lead
nothing into the count
and rivera bounces it left side arnado
steps on the bag fires the first and got
him it's a double play
yachty grounded out to short first time
up
yachty rips it to third they were on the
line that's rivera low throw and santana
couldn't come up with it yadi will stay
put it first
it'll be an error
the cardinals
have their third base runner of the
night
here's a 1-1 pitch
did that happen twice
i believe he punched him out again what
does he have against this kid lars dupar
is a pretty nice guy and you rang them
up twice on the second pitch
i don't care where this is it better be
a ball we saw that right didn't we yes
here's a 1-2
okay the uh one strike pitch
here it is umpire's reaction
[Applause]
and that's strike two
i love the follow-up
strike two
somebody missed their work out today
he's trying to get a little extra in
oh boy
here's a 2-2 pitch to lars neupar
lined
and a base hit into center
molina will stop at second
and here comes the crowd
sosa base hit into center field
sosa chops it up the middle slowly hit
under the glove of nikki lopez and nupar
hustling beats it out at the back new
bart as he beat it
oh i don't know we'll see here it comes
safe
and now the base is loaded for tommy
edmond the one
edmond hits it left side base hit molina
will score here comes newt barr
cardinals have the lead and it's 2-1 on
a bases loaded single by tommy edmond
[Applause]
two on two outs goldie at the plate
into center
and down
one run in here comes another goal he
drives in a pair
four one
st louis now it's arenado at the plate
the 2-2
arenado
into left
will it stay fair it is gone
6-1
red birds
good pitch struck him
out swing and a miss and a strikeout
the one-two
swing and a miss helsley with three
strikeouts in the inning
strands a pair
6-1 as we head to the eighth
base hit by bader base hit sosa edmund
the walk all loaded up
goldschmidt with a high fly ball
out to left center
and caught by taylor
all the runners will tag out one will
score that's bader and it's seven to one
they'll get a couple of guys in scoring
position for nolan arenado orinato is
homer tonight about another
fly ball deep left center
and gone
it's a home run
nolan oronato
how about another he obliged
well apparently it is a
double so one hopper over the wall we
saw the reaction of the crowd guys were
trotting around the bases including
nolan and you thought it might have been
a home run everybody was feeling it
on this special night for whit he is one
for three with a walk
[Applause]
and there's his second hit of the game
and then he's going to drive in a run
nikki lopez might beat hanser alberto to
the plate
it's a two-run double on a historic
night for whitmerfield two hits and a
walk two rbis
in his 422nd consecutive game
carlos grounds on right side he can
breathe a little easier
so the old for 21 is history and he
drives in with
2-2 pitch
by cabrera
he struck him out ends it with a
strikeout
the cardinals
have won five in a row
they're now 60 and 56 and we'll look for
another sweep tomorrow afternoon